Ross, you have the next story,
and I have to just put my personal investment stamp on it.
It might be my favorite story of the month.
Oh, okay. Well, okay, well listen to this, okay.
Who here has spent time or energy
worrying about what someone else
might be thinking about you?
Anybody guilty about that? (crowd claps)
Well, if you're one of those people like us,
I have good news for you.
Psychology Today reports, hey, no one is thinking about you.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Congratulations.
We suffer so much worrying about what other people think
but experts say we chronically overestimate
how much they think about us.
And we always think it's like way harsher
than what people are actually thinking.
Researchers have studied this.
Erica Booth calls it the likability gap.
Studies show if you pair two people for a conversation,
afterwards they always think the other person
was more interesting than that person probably found them.
Think about that.
How many times after a date or a meeting,
you're in the car or the train,
you're thinking like, "Why did I say that?"
"They probably think I'm an idiot".
"Why did I..."
And that, person's just thinking like,
"What's for lunch?"
You know, they're not thinking about you. (crowd laughs)
Yes, and I'm someone who really goes for it.
I go for a lot of jokes
and I'm kind of like a big personality.
So sometimes I really have those, oh my God.
Like, what did I just do moments,
but the calming, soothing humility
to hear from Psychology Today,
a renowned medical journal periodical,
that people are not sitting there obsessing about you
the way you're obsessing about them obsessing about you.
Yes.
This is such good news.
It's like, forget about it.
Yeah, I actually loved this motion, ha. (laughs)
Forget about it.
All right, well, next up,
we love to take brand new products for a spin,
and today we've got one,
and these are from your suggestions that you write in,
it's time for Drew's Reviews.
Hey. (crowd cheers and claps)
Okay.
All right.
Today's review is suggested from none other than Paula Rose.
Thank you, Paula.
We're trying the cheeseburger burrito
from the mad food scientists at Trader Joe's.
So it's apparently the perfect marriage between two foods,
the burrito and the cheeseburger.
Yeah. I'm holding a burrito
but it smells like secret sauce from a hamburger.
You know what I'm talking?
Like that thousand island pickly beefy cheesy, yes.
Well, should we try it?
Yeah, cheers.
Cheers.
(both make appreciative sounds)
(Drew chuckles)
Ooh.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Oh my God.
You know what it tastes like?
A cheeseburger burrito.
(crowd laughs)
It's interesting because I'm getting
all the goodness of the cheeseburger, like forward.
You know how it's like bun and condiments
and then you get to the meat.
This is like almost working the inside out.
Like it's burger first, then cheese
and then a little bit of like that flowery dough
you want, but not too much.
Trader Joe's, you've done it again.
Did it again. (crowd cheers and claps)
Well, it's time to rate it, Rossi.
How many stars outta five do you give it?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 stars, Trader Joe's.
And I second that with five stars.
Oh my goodness, I love it.
Thank you, Paula.
(upbeat theme music)